closing the gaps is quite literally
about closing the gaps between employers
and potential employees we visit local
businesses to determine their needs
including any possible work placements
we support potential employees into the
workplace having the closing the gaps
program in gore is incredibly important
for us as a community i believe
we're in a unique position where we're
part of a nationwide group of mayors
who have joined forces with the
government have provided funding
to allow us to make sure that we're
connecting
all of those younger people that are
looking for opportunities whether they
be people that are coming back into our
community whether they're people that
are coming up through our community at
the moment our target audiences are
neets or people not in education
employment or training between the ages
of 16 and 24
or people displaced by covert of any age
or people who have health or disability
challenges
and we can support businesses by
subsidizing employee costs including
training
employee costs compliance costs safety
costs tools equipment
i think in all trades today
um getting some
assistance
gives the employers that first six to
twelve months a bit of ease and uh
financially for their wages and their
boots and their pe gear and things like
that that we have to buy what this grant
assists us with the existing staff we've
got helping assist with their training
for their professional development
and
we'll get some decent accountants at the
other end of it so we're more than happy
it takes a lot to step from a classroom
into a job and without being given that
training and on-site experience there's
just like you can continue doing more
courses but it's been a lot faster and
beneficial for us to be able to just do
it on site it's been really cool to come
back home to a small town and work with
quite a close office firstly and then
also with
your clients you get to know and
yeah it's quite cool to be
personal level with them the last six
months have been pretty full-on but
really good work so i'm learning a lot
every day as well
about the trade
seeing that the benefit of
being able to facilitate those
discussions has been
really invigorating and certainly the
results on both sides have been
fantastic when you talk to employers
they love the opportunity to to spend a
bit of time with these
young people who are enthusiastic and
the young people getting real benefit
out of it so long term i think that's
fantastic for the gore district so if
you're looking for anyone or if you are
looking for work then please get in
touch with us